aiuto
[Musica]
ok
hai visto non è successo niente
[Applauso]
guarda o qualcosa per te
ciao merlino o meglio
[Musica]
siamo berlino come stai
no non si mangia è
se il tuo nuovo amico berlino
no no non si mangia berlino non si
mangia
[Musica]
che cos'è quella
merlino lo vedi anche tu quella stampa
vita e ma che cosa c'è
di tutto bene quando sono passato un po
di pressing cupolino esercizi
ok ti lascio fare agli esercizi allora
donna fra poco è ok ciao
[Musica]
che cosa starà succedendo deve essere
stato il morso del lupo per fortuna è
solo un piede
dure zampe è sicuramente stato il lupo
che mi ha morso forse mi sto
trasformando in un lupo mannaro o in un
lupo lo sapevo come la ragione è vitale
non avrei mai dovuto aprire quella
scatola non avrei mai dovuto prendere
quel telefono non avrei mai dovuto
rispondere al telefono perché non l'ho
ascoltato ho un'idea per nascondere
queste zone
ma che cosa sono quelle che sono le mie
bellissime le ciabattine unicorno perché
che c'è di male ok professor chiederti
se vivi a mangiare un gelato fuori in
giardino che ne pensi la bella idea ci
godiamo questa bella giornata di sole ok
ti raggiungo tra poco inizia ad andare
ok ok io intanto vado a dopo ok a dopo
perciò fare qualcosa
non essere scoperta
berlino aiutami tu che cosa posso fare
per interrompere la trasformazione
dammi un consiglio
ok grazie
proverò a fare finta di niente allora
[Musica]
vogliamo realizzare non si accorga di
niente
e perché perno così
[Musica]
qualcosa di strano in bocca o no no no
no no non mi diede quello che penso
no
[Musica]
senso
o no inizia vi si sta insospettendo è
meglio che esco subito e lo raggiungo
così non sospettare di niente
o no scarpe non vi entrano con quasi
zampe
che cosa possono perderlo
ok ragazzi ho solo fatto una soluzione
per i piedi
speriamo che l'italia non si accorga di
niente
eccomi ciao mib a
vivere su un cerotto anche per me no non
venivi più e quindi ho detto ok io
comincio a mangiare il mio gelato
proprio questo caldo magari si scioglie
se lo prendevo pure per terra
tu sei sempre lenta
sei sempre il solito potevi prendere un
gelato anche per me ma cosa sia successo
ai denti
niente perché parli anche in modo strano
no si procura il mondo giornalistico
no non parli in modo normale non visto
pure qualcosa fammi vedere in
che strano perché non mi dai un pezzo di
sia nato in belgio lato il mio nonno
gambe no no
vatti a prendere il suo gelato
musicalnews la do dammi un pezzo di
gelato
vitale stai bene io non volevo non
volevo
spaventarti non sa che cosa sia successo
ma quelli quelli che cosa sono niente
sono cresciuti adesso
cosa è successo lì
che cosa ti è successo ai piedi anche
questi sono cresciuti adesso piedi
pelosi
ma dove sono
il mio gelato
solo tu calmati comodi vitale e il
gelato mai mangiato più o meno poi
insomma si svenuta in giardino cosa
svenuto in giardino perché e beh è una
lunga storia
prima per i miei denti da lupo mannaro e
poi per i miei piedi pelosi
[Musica]
spero ci sia una spiegazione a tutto
questo si c'è uno sfigato ignorati
racconto tutto e mi spiace in una parte
l'ho detto prima ma speravo che tutto si
risolvesse da solo senza che ti dovresti
dire niente ma le cose stanno
peggiorando
anzi penso che la trasformazione stia
progredendo e se non facciamo qualcosa
subito mi trasformerò completamente in
un lupo mannaro
trasformazione lupo mannaro
ma cosa stai dicendo ti ricordi che mi
avevi detto di non aprire mai più la
scatola e non prendere mai più niente
dalla scatola
sì certo che me lo ricordo beh c'era un
telefono che squillava insomma è una
lunga storia e poi mi hanno risposto e
poi era un'altra prova e io ho risposto
anche se non avrei dovuto rispondere poi
sono qualità che non si sa ora mangerò
un lupo poi il look
e venuto qua in camera e poi lui mi ha
morso e penso che sia nel lupo che mi ha
morso che mi ha iniziato trasformare il
lupo mannaro il lupo il piano di sopra
che un punto informazioni non sto
capendo più niente
come possiamo fare ad interrompere
questa trasformazione adesso ha un idea
io penso che la trasformazione si
completerà non appena arriverà la luna
piena
quindi dobbiamo sbrigarci a trovare una
soluzione prima che arrivi la luna piena
quindi abbiamo pochissime ore in realtà
e se invece arriverà la luna piena forse
rimarrò per sempre un
no la casa orgosolo sta continuando
dobbiamo sbrigarci alla luna piena mi
trasformerò per sempre in un lupo
mannaro
spieghiamo ci troviamo una soluzione mi
metto subito cercherà una soluzione va
bene mi raccomando però non metterti a
mangiare ok in uno come vederlo questa
sera mi metto mangiate così dire no no
no va bene anche io cercherò una
soluzione fa prima che sia troppo tardi
ok ok vedo che cosa posso trovare
riuscirà la vita la troveremo
assoluzione
e poi lasciate un mi piace per aiutarmi
a trovare una soluzione mi raccomando
cliccate mi piace qua sotto abbiamo
pochissime ore di tempo
no
[Musica]
perfetto
ci sono riuscita ho limato tutti i denti
aguzzi dove comandare adesso mi mancano
solo le zampe forse posso tornare ad
essere normale
[Musica]
andrò per questo devo andare ad abitare
vitale
questo e berlino qui dove chi come te
visto
davanti maggio
devo subito fissare vitale evitare ieri
subita qua è chiamato
cosa di successo la trasformazione sta
progredendo dobbiamo subito fare
qualcosa sì una cenetta forza una
ceretta è così ampio non togliamo quelli
perdite questo è un momento di scherzare
dovremmo trovare una soluzione prima che
arrivi la luna piena e vi trasformerà
completamente in un lupo mannaro
permette io non stavo scherzando però ci
si era già la ragione è meglio meglio
gira subito ho chiesto berlino cosa ne
pensa delle mie orecchie ma è un po
strano
wow ma sono morbidissime e anche
velocissime
si va quindi che cosa facciamo io ho
provato una cosa o li moto i denti vedi
quando torna di normale non ho più i
denti aguzzi da lupo mannaro quindi
forse posso provare a tagliare le zampe
tagliare le orecchie un po pericoloso
però potrei farvi un po male sì direi
proprio di sì ma aspetta un attimo stavo
pensando se tu ti trasformi il lupo con
la luna piena
perché non facciamo l'effetto contrario
cioè magari riusciamo in giardino e
quindi con l'effetto del sole forse
annulla l'effetto della luna piena non
ho mai sentito niente del genere così
come non abbiamo nessun altra
possibilità siamo provare nei chioschi
torniate a riguardo però proviamoci voi
cosa ne pensate
funzionerà andiamo dai berlino andiamo
giardino e te ne vai sdraiati qua nella
macaé prendi un po di sole di via subito
no non penso che funzionerà ma proviamo
a caldissimo oggi
che brutto
[Musica]
sentite anche voi questo rumore
vitale dove è finito
[Musica]
stai mangiando
meno è quello che cos'è il busto da dire
non ci credo si è voluto uscire fuori in
giardino solo per mangiare no no siamo
usciti fuori per per aiutarti nella
trasformazione poi già che c'ero
lo trovate le patatine poi non permette
a tagliare un po sono ancora buona
[Musica]
beh questa soluzione non ha funzionato
quindi torniamo in casa si concorda
anche perché ho finito le patatine
sanità
no niente ti volevo giusto dire una cosa
che
non so come dirtelo non ti spaventare ma
mi sa che la trasformazione sta
continuando
perché che cosa è successo guarda di
dietro non ti spaventare però
non c'è niente che cosa è successo
che guarda dietro di te
dietro c'è una palma non ho attaccato
proprio
capito mi stai prendendo in giro senti
io domando visto la presenza in giro
cosa che c'è qualcosa dietro di te
guarda che non ti sto prendendo in giro
non ti sembra abbastanza che ho le
orecchie del zampe vuoi anche prendermi
in giro
portate stessa allora questo che cos'è
hai visto che non ti stavo prendendo in
giro
[Musica]
è già vivo
devo andare a vedere le ruspe che
ci mancava pure la cosa la prossima cosa
cosa farà allora
i baffi ma non si può togliere
credo di no e allora cosa facciamo
un'idea berlino è un cane quindi forse
lui potrebbe scappare la soluzione
proviamo a chiedere a lui perché tu
discende dai lupi vero puoi dirmi qual è
la soluzione per non trasformare il lupo
mannaro
aiutano il mattino
che cosa devo fare per interrompere la
trasformazione
non so se berlino ha capito guarda
berlino nei di queste esatte vogliono
dire che mi sto trasformando in un lupo
mannaro
anche queste ore che guarda
non si mangiano e guarda una cosa devo
sbrigarmi capisci cosa potrei fare per
interrompere la trasformazione
andando dirà forse devo seguirlo andiamo
e in berlino
dimmi dove devo andare per trovare la
soluzione
quindi devo aprire questa porta ok
ho capito
devo salire questo provero no quindi
tornerò indicato ma riguarda sta
guardando la sopra sopra le scale a
chiocciola nel soffitto
vi ricordate cosa c'è nella soffitta
si sa che devo per forza tornare là
sopra forse ritrovare una soluzione in
genere il berlino non si sbaglia mai
quindi forse la soprattutto per una
soluzione perde trasformarmi e tornare
normali e andiamo anche sbrigarvi però
perché non si sbaglia mai ma se ti
succede qualcosa che cosa faccio io non
so se sia una buona idea che tu venga
con me perché potresti essere morso
anche due se diventiamo entrambi di lupi
mannari non riusciremo mai a far parte
quindi devo andare io da solo ok tu
rimani qui ad ascoltare ok ma per io
rimango qui pertanto vari sbrigati
sbrigati
fra poco pero lasciato mi piace per
portarmi fortuna
[Musica]
il mio boh
stavo uscendo dalla camera
[Applauso]
riesco a capirlo
ma cosa starà succedendo lassù
sento dei rumori strani
[Musica]
gelato
e l'altro al cioccolato
patatine flash
tutto negando
[Musica]
no
6 l'occhio marley no
[Musica]
[Risate]
mettiti difendere il tuo padrone devo
trasformando
[Musica]
così un lupo bucate la iena aiuto
mamma mia che paura
guarda guarda c'è la luna piena si
domandarono devi devi obbedire alla luna
di hera come si dice non lo so davanti
c'è nessuna una piega e ancora il giorno
o no è vero che il coraggio
però
sono riuscito a chiudere la porta
ma che cosa è successo mi sono
addormentato anita si è trasformata cosa
devo fare adesso non lo so
idea
forse ne posso parlare ma riuscirà a
capire se le spiego che c'è qualcosa che
non va in lei sì le parlerò ma è visto
che strano aveva un occhio da lupo è un
occhio da umano che imita scusami siete
o chiusa fuori ma avevo paura che mi
spronasse
adesso pure non la porta e mi raccomando
non mi sbranare poi possiamo parlare in
fondo
va bene
sto per aprire una porta
[Musica]
piano piano
voglio solo parlarsi in fondo
[Musica]
ok io ce sto cassa certi assaggiarli io
sono buono lo scopriremo molto presto
aspetta aspetta
ieri qua parliamone ti devo spiegare
nelle cose prima
che era nelle cose sono semi la vera
vita c'è una maledizione su di te chi
sta trasformando lentamente il lupo
quindi non pensare che sono il lupo tu
non mi vuoi mangiare che ti ricordi che
siamo fidanzati non mi vorrai mica a
mangiare poi guarda non bayern che cosa
c'è perché mi stai guardando così
immediato che ho sbagliato io in realtà
voglio
mangiare perché vorresti mai a fare una
cosa del genere
che potresti essere molto buone da
mangiare non sono buona da mangiare
guarda poi sono pieno di peli potrei
essere un lupo mannaro non sono
assolutamente buono da mangiare anzi
guarda con tutte quelle cose che ma non
potrei anche essere velenoso magari
stai male dopo è qualcosa che non va 20
no no meglio non mangiare vitale
beh va beh allora ci fosse una catena
porterai
non sento morte si è speso perché così
potrai trasformare
come è pronto no basta
no no no
no
[Musica]
mi è venuta un'idea andrò a chiedere
consiglio a qualcuno sicuramente mi
saprà aiutare questa qui magrino stai
attento resta qui vero
[Musica]
perfino
o no la porta aperta manita
cosa facciamo adesso merlino
amico è scappata sarebbe essersi
nascosta in qualsiasi parte in questa
casa berlino
avvisami se per caso senti l'odore di
anita qui in giro da qualche parte e
questo cos'è
patatine
aspetta un attimo
sembra ci siano delle tracce qui
faccio di patatine
vediamo dove portano
wow che fortuna ho trovato un sentiero
di patatine che mi porta ad una busta di
patatine proprio per me wow allora
adesso mi metto proprio qui e mele
maggio c'è qualcuno che mi vuole bene
non è noto mondo poi mandare a madrid e
paolo porta
[Musica]
che strano mi sono messi prato di sentir
rumore
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta non sei
del tutto trasformata sei ancora anita
non sei un lupo mannaro quindi tu non
vuoi mordermi tu non puoi mangiarne c'è
ancora delbono inter non sei un lupo
mannaro
io devo fermare la trasformazione e devo
fermarla prima che arrivi la luna piena
che mi credi
e che è troppo tardi
[Musica]
o no
tra poco la vita si trasformerà in un
completo lupo mannaro tutto procede
secondo i piani colora
[Musica]
avete capito che sono venuto a trovare
qua sopra
per la chiedere aiuto al lupo lui
sicuramente saprà aiutarci e no
spero proprio di sì
[Musica]
ecco vi ricordate di questa porta il
lupo vive proprio qua dentro
anita aveva già provato a bussare qui a
chiedere il suo aiuto
quindi adesso ci troviamo che noi
[Musica]
fino al lupo
[Applauso]
cosa sta facendo
aprendo il lucchetto
signor lupo
salve signor rupo possa disturbare
all'istante
avrei bisogno del suo aiuto per
per salvare la vita e come si sta si sta
trasformando in un nuovo mandato è
vorrei intraprendere questa
trasformazione
mi può aiutare per questo
era un sì lì è come te deve essere stata
morsa da un po da un lupo mannaro
ed è così che è iniziata la
trasformazione
cosa stai facendo
[Musica]
sembra che stia scrivendo su un foglio
[Applauso]
così non capisco
[Musica]
cosa dice proviamo a leggere questo
foglio mi dispiace sono stato io a
morderla è stato lui a mordere la vita
allora e ad iniziare la trasformazione
ma stavo solo eseguendo
degli ordini e di chi però ora che il
mio capo non mi vede posso aiutarti
segui bene queste indicazioni
[Musica]
ehi ma
non è andata a vita
o no non mi dire che sta tentando di
scappare
devo andare a fermarla se sono ancora in
tempo
[Musica]
too often andata anita
qui non si vede
dove si sarà nascosta
il 15
c'è chi aspetta un attimo quello cos'è
ehi ma che ci fai la sotto lascia
pregustare dal muretto ed auguri pietà
quota altare dal muretto no non puoi
andare ti farai male è altissimo il muro
brano mi faccio male perché perché
prezzo lo mette al lupo
aspetta aspetta aspetta ti farò morte
del mio braccio mi dispiace ma non puoi
fermarmi ora che sono metto al lupo e
sta per arrivare la luna piena devo
cercare le predette addio no no no
aspetta aspetta aspetta diventare non
andare
lì e ti farò dare un mostro al mio
braccio se scendi subito dal muretto che
gli uffici del brano che no prima devi
scendere ed entrare dentro grafica non è
quindi ti farai mordere trasformare il
lupo mannaro anche tu sì lo farò non
m'interessano fuori troverò molto più
breve e no e dovrei cercarle le prede e
le dovrei trasformare e invece io sono
già qua ti basta un morto e mezzo ha
trasformato
da io sono di tale poi diventerà un lupo
mannaro li metteremo allenati e
prenderemo più prete no ma solo quel che
faccio più in fretta trasformarsi in
lupo mannaro ok andiamo dai
adesso l'inter in casa che supporti
board rip si guarda dovreste un attimo
allungare quel cassetto lì ma per quel
cassetto per qualcosa non aver paura
davvero guardare
[Musica]
troppo fredde
brutta luna piena star
4t fatto fare un modo di sera voi da il
primo baby le di aria scappiamo
scappiamo sono riuscito a scappare o no
ora cosa faccio per procedere secondo i
piani
anita deve rimanere sotto controllo in
casa ma non posso di certo farmi mordere
però ho un piano
venite con me andiamo
o no
venite scappata c'è la porta aperta come
ha fatto ad aprire la porta devo trovare
la subito prima che faccia delle altre
vittime non può uscire da sola fuori
scapperà di nuovo e prenderà qualcun
altro
[Musica]
cioè anita
berlino ariston ita 6 dove è andata
da quella parte grazie merlino
sì l'ho presa lo catturata
e adesso rimane
da crociera
sinistra nata ormai non mi scriverai
sono quasi deciso e chiuderlo
ci sono riuscito
da bruxelles
[Musica]
[Risate]
facciamo silenzio è notte fonda
sono riuscito a chiudere a vita nella
tenda si può sapere perché mi hai chiuso
qua dentro perché se pericolosa
volta sì è vero se pericolosa e c'è la
luna piena oggi è sicuramente 6
pericolosa per me ma magari tu sei anche
per gli altri quindi è meglio se seguo
il consiglio che mi ha dato il lupo e ti
tengo gli usa fa dentro e va bene allora
se vi va il mio stile ti prometto che
non ti mangerò no non ti credo che lo
giuro
non ti credo comunque non può passare
tutto il tempo chiesa qua dentro
e come se vuoi stare e invece no rimarrà
in chiusa fa dentro finché non passa la
luna piena e arriva il mattino io usa
che adesso mi faccio anche un pisolino
no devi rimanere qua dentro sofferto
[Musica]
ecco
che c'è
sono qui e
ti sei addormentato non ho
fame [ __ ] no ti ho detto di no ti devo
sorvegliare devo rimanere sveglio tutta
la notte ma perché che cosa succederà
quando arriva alla luna piena
niente non succederà niente
mi sento mi sento un po strana che senso
strada sta succedendo qualcosa che cosa
sta succedendo guarda che è meglio che
aprì la tenda c'è qualcosa di strano
non ne sono così sicuro non è che mi sta
ingannando no
no piero la pro la tenda sitra sessione
di quel punto a piè di lista pessina ti
miopia scappo scappo scappò anita
cercato di folder mi attraverso la tenda
ma so io come sistemarla adesso
la sistemo io adesso con questi i
paletti per la tenda a chi chi chi chi
ora visto la tenda così la vita non
potrà più scappare nemmeno con la tenda
piano le dita
che cosa stai facendo
niente sto schiacciando le noci voi ma
no c'è in tutti i rumori strani che cosa
stai facendo un martello
eh sì sto aprendo le noci col martello
dai fissandola te in dal terreno
da gioco è
fatto
ora non potrei che appare più da nessuna
parte di chi si è visto ho visto va bene
perché non credo
mi rimetto questo momento che cosa
no no theatrical
adesso non andrà da nessuna parte
[Musica]
vero
prova
sta succedendo
omero
o no
sta succedendo
via via
o no
la trasformazione è cominciata non sono
riuscito a tenerla nico lupo mannaro
chiuso nella tenda e adesso che cosa
farà scapperà e cercherà di mangiarmi
oppure andrà alla ricerca di altre
persone magari no non so che cosa devo
fare
ma
[Musica]
è enorme
che cosa facciamo adesso
[Musica]
contro sembra stia venendo qui dentro
casa con no adesso mi mangia che cosa
devo fare
[Musica]
berlino berlino tutti su un cane aiutami
il lupo mannaro nella sua forma massima
che cosa dobbiamo fare adesso
scappiamo
ci prenderà si mangerà
sta arrivando
[Musica]
mi sono addormentato
a il lupo
a quella umanità
carità
come va
al succo e il giardino è una storia un
po lunga ma ti ricordi niente di che
cosa di quello che è successo ieri sera
no che cos'è successo
gli fanno in comune le braccia e la
schiena ma come non si ricordi niente
per un lupo mannaro volevi mangiarmi
mangiarti non credo proprio non vorrei
mai mangiardi lei o caldo torno dentro
spetta ti devo spiegare che cosa è
successo perché non mi credi
che sono mi sembra di non aver dormito
per tutta la notte e infatti è così non
hai dormito tutta la notte ti sei
trasformata in lupo mi ha rincorso
volevi sbranarmi è quindi direi che per
quello che sei un po stanco ma che dici
se mi fossi trasformate in lupo sarei
ancora lupo nomi dormire loro nuovo
aspetto è meglio se non ti addormenti
che strumenti ritrasformi di nuovo il
lupo si sa mai guarda che mi so magari
ti risvegli di nuovo lungo un sogno
troppo stanca lasciami in pace si sta
addormentando devo trovare un modo per
tenerla sveglia
svegliati lasciami
[Musica]
tutte le volte che proverete ad
adattarti non ero un pò pazzo
ma ho bisogno di dormire sveglia ei
metti la moto smetterò sveglia smettila
che cosa stai facendo
sono stata io a ringhiare avete visto
anche voi marino sei stato tu a
ringhiare no non è stato merlino berlino
vuole mangiare tutti i pupazzi ben senti
io sono troppo stanca torno a dormire
senza aspetta aspetta una cosa per te è
una letterata parte del lupo te lo
ricordi il lupo al lupo
sì mi ricordo di lui e come lasciato
questa lettera per te
c'è un sigillo
con un lupo
vediamo cosa c'è scritto
una lettera scritta a mano c'è scritto
ciao anita per fortuna la sua prima
notte da completo lupo mannaro è andata
bene non hai fatto nessuna vittima
il capo è molto arrabbiato per questo e
anche perché vi aiutati ti contatterà
molto presto fai tutto quello che ti
dice almeno fino a quando non avrai
rotto la maledizione si forte come un
lupo firmato l
che cosa dovremmo fare adesso che il
capo di cui parla non lo so non te li ho
parlato no mi ha salutato la lettera ha
solo detto che quando che ha morso stava
solo eseguendo gli ordini del suo capo
non ne ho idea di chi sia quindi lui in
realtà non è cattivo non mi ha morso per
trasformarmi il lupo mannaro
no non credo forse come dice lui stava
solo eseguendo gli ordini non lo so
come ho fatto chiudersi alla volta sta
arrivando qualcuno o no
chi è
chi sei
c'è berlino dimmi tu chi è
meglio tenerlo porta chiusa qualsiasi
cosa sia non voglio che il 34
[Musica]
una lettera un'altra lettera il sigillo
diverso come il sigillo è diverso che
cos'è
un lupo un ufo
sono lasciato questa lettera
dovremmo aprire secondo voi state un mi
piace qui sotto se volete che offriremo
e leggiamo questa lettera il simbolo è
della faccia di un lupo e c'è anche una
chiave qua spero che non sia una
trappola
un'idea facciamola annusare a berlino è
lui con il suo intuito rifiuto
riuscirà a capire se una trappola o se
possiamo aprirla ottima idea per lì non
ci ha sempre aiutato in queste
situazioni prime occhiate vederlo prima
rino guarda dimmi se pericolosa o se
posso aprirlo che è senza mangiarla però
è
sempre di sì e berlino sembra commettere
meta prova dopo senza fare le cose non
possono che sta provando ad aprirla
quindi vuol dire che dobbiamo
decisamente aprirla si può nemmeno non
si sbaglia mai
grazie per il tuo aiuto berlino grazie
berlino sta ancora provando a mangiarla
ma io la pro adesso no berlino non si
mangia
[Musica]
ok vedremo che cosa c'è dentro
una lettera ciao anita però tu ti sia
divertite a scoprire la forza e i poteri
no berlino non vuoi te lo leggo marino
non vuole che le canalette ra perché che
c'è berlino potrebbe farmi male cercando
di fermarmi nel ri note fa per forza a
leggerla potrebbe esserci qualche
indizio qua non capisco cosa vuole dirmi
merlino si legge la rai vediamo che cosa
dice la vanità spero tu ti sia divertita
a scoprire la forza e i poteri del lupo
mannaro ma non pensare che sia finita
qui infatti ad ogni luna piena tornerà
il lupo mannaro cosa avevi ragione non è
fantastico
ah ah ah se vuoi rompere la maledizione
dovrai superare tutte le prove a e poi
ovviamente ci sarà la prova finale fa
cassa ma ora è meglio che inizi il
viaggio perché il tempo sta passando e
la prossima luna piena si avvicina seguì
la mappa e ricorda se non verrai lupo
mannaro per sempre rimarrà firmato il re
il re il re di col bayern ma c'è
qualcosa qui
sembra una mappa una mappa sembra la
mappa del tesoro ma non penso che sia la
mappa del tesoro ma gli diceva dovrà
iniziare il viaggio ho capito dobbiamo
metterci in viaggio dobbiamo fare queste
varietà riguarda c'è un castello dei
lupi questo non so cosa sia un portale
che cosa è questa chiave invece a che
cosa servirà meglio portarla con noi
quante saranno le tappe
soprattutto dove dobbiamo andare prima
al castello forse
penso che il primo percorso sia il
castello come ha detto nella lettera più
tempo passa più la luna piena si
avvicina io potrei tornare lupo mannaro
e potrei realmente sbranarti
quindi dobbiamo sbrigarci dobbiamo fare
tutte queste tappe secondo voi sarà
pericoloso che cosa succederà una volta
che arriviamo al castello presso
dobbiamo metterci in viaggio subito
dobbiamo partire subito perso questi
punti prima che torni la luna piena è
anche il percorso da seguire e voi
verrete con noi ci porterete fortuna che
cosa succederà secondo voi lasciate un
mi piace per portarci fortuna qua sotto
iniziamo subito il viaggio si andiamo
già abbiamo in
viaggio ti amo tanto direzione castello
e ci aspettano sette ore di viaggio in
macchina a voi piacciono i viaggi in
macchina o preferite i viaggi in aereo
scrivetelo nei commenti
abbiamo tutto l'essenziale per il
viaggio in macchina
cappellino crema solare per non
scottarsi acqua nella borraccia termina
così rimane fredda per un sacco di ore e
parasole e voi verrete insieme a noi
arriveremo stanotte al castello in
effetti sarà un po più
inquietante vedere il castello per la
prima volta di note passeremo la prima
notte nel castello e voi sarete sempre
con noi è bellissimo perché sembra che
poi state vedendo in viaggio con noi
vedo l'ora di mangiare che per noi siamo
i ragazzi siamo stanchissimi soprattutto
vitali anche a martyrs infatti appena
arriverà vitale di matera la le mura del
castello il ponte del castello che
cos'altro ti amo arrivando al castello
temo molto in salita ha detto non si
capisce
stiamo entrando nella foresta che arriva
al castello
per arrivare per fortuna non è proprio
buio buio buio c'è un pochettino di luce
la strada è un pò strada è tutta in
salita io ti ho fatto sono in alto
questo capitello
eccoci ragazzi e con il castello ora
entriamo devo entra duro il castello
come sarà
[Musica]
[Applauso]
si parla a bassa voce perché notte fonda
stiamo per entrare dentro al cartello
abbia un po di paura perché è un pò
inquietante di notte è
bellissimo guardate
ciao
wow è bellissimo è un vero castello
dobbiamo ora andare nella nostra stanza
la nostra ti mura del castello che
sopra queste star
speriamo che non ci sia niente di strano
dentro cosa troveremo nella stanza
secondo voi
abbiamo il nostro orticello
parlo e bellissimo essere in un vero
castello e ora entriamo nella nostra
stanza la nostra stanza si chiama dal
ponte levatoio e chiusi qua qua possiamo
parlare a voce un pochino più alta
perché anche se notte fonda siamo chiusi
nella nostra stanza facciamo un rum tour
ma che stai facendo sto vedendo se c'è
qualche cosa da mangiare un po 20 a un
pasto del dei primi dell'ottocento
tutti questi anche potrebbe esserci
qualcosa di pericoloso qua dentro
no no
è vuoto bene o male
effetti non metterti ad aprire tutto
perché potrebbe uscire qualcosa di
strano
allora nevoso frigo
problema il problema che il frigo vuoto
mi dispiace per te se vuoi puoi
mangiarti il ponte levatoio ei pezzi di
pietra nel cartello a un po croccante ma
vabbè si può fare
esploriamo la nostra auto ricambi ma non
troppo emozionata di essere in un vero
castello d'oro sempre sognato di vivere
in un castello
intero castello e fan tutti allora qua
abbiamo un
divano
grandissimo e vitale se russa a dormire
acqua cercherà di mangiarsi cosino
in realtà ho visto qualcos'altro che si
può mangiare
[Musica]
cioccolatini vista bizarre rubando senza
dirmi niente
lascia di qua continuiamo il nostro team
ferite 20 abbiamo il titano di quella
specie di armadio strano un altro armadi
decide al tempo che in questa sembra che
potresti nasconderci un paio di persone
cosa è un paio di persone colata terzo è
bellissimo adoro tutto e poi ovviamente
tutto in piedi tra il muro il soffitto
in legno sono queste due tende per
chiudere qua non so che cosa sia
forse nasconde qualcosa che serva una
finestra una finestra così piccola si è
una finestra piccolino teniamo
fortuna finestra piccolino e non vedo
niente niente
[Musica]
ci credo ma non c'è niente
da fare una fine
so che cosa è una feritoia giusta una
feritoia infatti le feritoie nei
castelli al tempo venivano usate per
colpire i nemici quello sono così
strette così non potevano essere colpiti
dai nemici non potevano colpire i nemici
[Musica]
guardate
ecco quando vedrete potete vedere un
pochettino
dell'albero che c'è fuori dal però no
non c'è niente da mangiare le dispiaceva
linee anzi qualcosa di interessante
perché qua sopra c'è un pezzo di legno
forse prima qua sarà una finestra più
grande e poi è stata murata per qualche
motivo
dispero sicuramente in questo castello
si sono un pò di segreti che motori
riusciamo a svelare comunque continuiamo
il tour e dalla nostra storia così solo
due tende poi abbiamo questa colonna
questo è un po già cibo per vitale
una finestra si segue una finestra ho
paura ad aprirla polpa
apriamola alla fine poi c'è questa
poltrona da re o regina molto molto
comoda amboy abbiamo
un affresco con il simbolo che potrebbe
significare qualcosa al fresco
sì questa è la famosa torta della nonna
e via tortona non è fatta così arrotonda
il disegno di fiore la torta della nonna
fatta con le mele il pinoli e
abbiamo un'altra comodissima poltrona
del re vogata rosina e abbiamo due sedie
che sono delle sedie medievali
e se ti e belle ma scomodissimo
[Musica]
si dice qualcosa gioco così via di
guardare cibo dove niente è impossibile
che c'è un telecomando dentro ad un
cartello e il telecomando del ponte
levatoio per alzare o abbassare il punto
ma sempre telecomando di una tv
è la tv effettivamente sì realta del
comando di una tv non è sul telecomando
del ponte levatoio da tempo volevo che i
coccodrilli le trovate qua c'è una
bellissima pista forse poi ora state
vedendo noi rifletti ma in realtà c'è
una bellissima vista verso il cortile
del castello che domani vedremo meglio
con la luce del sole potremo meglio
esploreremo meglio il castello e filo
d'acqua un po si può vedere guardate
prima mou alla finestra
cortile del castello
[Musica]
bene ora che abbiamo fatto il rum tour
cosa ne pensate vi piace alla nostra
stanza in questo cartello ovviamente poi
domani vi faremo fare anche il castello
to brutto vedere meglio anche il
cappello ma ora vediamo cosa c'è
nella finestra si è anche dovuto aprire
la finestra misteriosa non vedo l'ora di
vedere che cosa sia piatta con la
finestra secondo te ed essenziale dietro
una vista sulle torri del castello i
cavalieri la difendono le note con i
cavalieri che la di beni durevoli
corazzate non sai cosa sarebbe la cosa
più inquietante degli oppressi questa
finestra ci fosse una persona che ci
guarda così
[Musica]
tanto è vero che cosa c'entra questa
finestra scrivetelo nei commenti prima
che io la presi ledian coface vediamo se
indovinate lasciate anche un bel mi
piace sotto questo video mi raccomando
che cosa c'è
la di musica
si vede la tv
il segreto del caffè ma sicuramente un
tempo non c'era ovviamente la tv ma
perché non esiste ma uniti per che cosa
c'era una finestra verso
un'altra parte del cartello forse delle
segrete e magari riusciranno scoprirlo
non credo però fossero le segrete perché
perché effettivamente sono segrete
nessuno le ha viste rho
qual è la parte che vi piace di più
dalla nostra camera del castello
dell'indeciso la poltrona da resine ora
che noi aderiamo le cose paurose
inquietanti quindi questa stanza è
perfetta per chi era un po inquietante
sembra che nasconda qualche strano
segreto ma forse se devo scegliere la
smetti di
questi si devono nascondere
è sempre il solito forse la mia cosa
preferita era vista da questo stanza
verso il cortile del castello
poi domani connessione vi faremo vedere
meglio e questo che cos'è è uno sgabello
non mi ero accorta che ci fossero uno
sgabello qua quelli sgabello è stato
messo apposta lì così ti poesie e
ammirare bellissimo paesaggio che si
vede beh cerchiamo di sopravvivere per
ora la prima notte nel castello su nel
vivere ma io già lo adoro il re mi ha
dato due cioccolatini e si fa
a prenderli ogni volta sono un mago che
sono sicuro di una cosa cosa vitale in
qualche modo ci
[Musica]
scrivete nei commenti dove devo
nascondere questi cioccolati in modo che
vitale non li trovi forse nell'armadio
inquietante forse nella feritoia fate
fanno sapere nei commenti così lo posso
scoprire andarli a mangiare
ha ovviamente messo più mi piace è stato
questo pubblici vediamo molto per
speriamo che il tempo è stato di
fantasmi
giorno al
castello guardate un po che bella
visuale abbiamo sul cortile interno del
castello vi piace il mio outfit mi sono
vestito un po
viziata no non farò vedere regia
battendo ancora mettervi le scarpe che è
già forte così le già fatti con le calze
per mettere le scarpe
o vai in posizione dello sgabello reale
per aver indossato le ciabatte con le
carte e rimane
il consiglio della tenda allora se possa
qualcuno là sotto
vede vitale tutto qua definire
va bene finita la tua punizione per aver
indossato i giubbotti con le cause però
devi metterti le scarpe ok voler mettere
le scarpe
hanno bussato vogliano aprire per no non
posso perché è solo in punizione stati
libero da una punizione da un no no
adesso devo dare un primo a mettere le
scarpe privo di andare no io non voglio
andare ad aprire è un po inquietante
quella porta non voglio andare ad aprire
dai vai tu uffa vado new york attento
controllo prima chi è chi è chi è
stato il vento o un fantasma non c'e
nessuno non c'è niente non hanno
lasciato niente non stanno bussando alla
porta adesso
la feritoia che abbiamo aperto ieri
notte forse qualcuno si è arrabbiato
perché l'abbiamo aperta senza permesso
forse il resto è arrabbiato o il
proprietario di questo cappello gli
abitanti di questo cappello che ancora
non abbiamo visto vediamo se c'è
qualcosa
apriamo questa
c'è una ragnatela gigante già giocato
aspetta qualcosa guarda quando ne avevi
tu lavano così impossibile che cadrai da
qua prendi con quella cosa che ce li
investirà forse c'è qualcosa piano piano
ma che cos'è ma
[Musica]
x momento di una lettera e il sigillo
del re il sigillo del lupo sì c'è
scritto una lettera forse vuole darci il
benvenuto
sì proviamo ad aprirla perché come sali
nella feritoia ho un'idea dopo usciamo
fuori e guardiamo questa feritoia da
fuori perché magari scopriamo dove abita
e dove realmente il rennes
c'è scritto benvenuti nel mio castello
in che sarete i miei ospiti
dovrete superare varie prove la prima
prova è esplorare il castello e scoprire
i suoi segreti
riuscirete a trovare il cavaliere
fate attenzione a non disturbare gli
abitanti centenari del castello a presto
e sopravviverete
sopravvivere li chiamo ma anche assenso
abitanti centenari ci sono forze tanti
vecchietti e penso che intende
qualcos'altro ma comunque è meglio che
iniziamo la prova subito flessore prima
che ci mandi qualche altra lettera o
qualcos'altro attraverso la feritoia c'è
molto video da esploriamo il castello si
prima mentre scarpe vero perché con le
ciabatte un po più difficile si no
questo è il terrazzo che avete visto
ieri al buio
telo sul ponte levatoio
[Musica]
guardarlo sembra faccia stradale tra
forse uno degli indizi uno degli
abitanti guarda
e un po inquietante
triste vediamo quante facce in pietra o
cose strane riusciamo a trovare anche
voi state attenti e scrivete nei
commenti tutte le facce o cose strane
che vedete ora nel castello ok andiamo
questo è il cortile del castello curate
che bello
parla a bassa voce perché il re ha detto
di non disturbare gli abitanti del
castello che potrebbero arrabbiarsi
[Musica]
guarda qui c'è un indizio
che cos'è sarò due uomini uno con un
fungo e uno la broccoli penso che
un fungo
ecco i giardini del castello vediamo
quante facce o creature nella pietra
riusciamo a trovare guardate
un po inquietante questo che cos'era
secondo tempo un drago sembra un gatto
gargoyle e sit notte questi professori
ta
[Musica]
finita sì
ma è solo una statua però se si
trasformasse anche lui queste erano i
proprietari del castello c'è questo
oppure sono dei parenti del re lo
scopriremo molto presto
spero che cos'era quel rumore per uno
sfogo mi chiede un po che del panorama
penso di aver scoperto qualcosa che cosa
c'è qualcosa di te
un ragno ma lo devo fare
è solo una statua
[Musica]
dove sta scappando vitale
6 conte patate con tutto questo marino
che si è fidato
e ancora pensando a mangiare
questi sono i giardini del castello
curati che belli si sono tantissime rose
a seguire sono bellissime
[Musica]
guardate abbiamo trovato una strana
cerchia di banchine riguardante
magari a queste erano solo le panchine
delle streghe questo è il circolo della
strega cercherò oggi colosio
siamo seduti qua nelle banchine delle
streghe si è vitale ha notato qualcosa
di strano
[Musica]
anche
inquietanti dobbiamo riuscire a trovare
tutte le creature sculture opposizioni
che troviamo perché porta e quello che
intendeva il regno come aumentando i
centenari e spero che non prendano vita
e se li ha trasformati in pietra perché
perché gli umani li ha trasformati in in
statue e li abbiamo visti qua sotto
gli animali con gli artigli li ha
trasformati in panchina
poverini che si trasformerà in stato
anche a noi allora forse è meglio
scappare via subito da questo castello
quando noi dovremmo scappare via subito
lasciate un mi piace qui sotto per
portarci fortuna io però prima di
scappare gli do castelo andrei a
mangiare un attimino qualcosa per me che
sono già non possiamo più avere lo
stomaco vuoto mi signore continuiamo a
cercare le creature è meglio che le
individuiamo tutti qualcosa coraggiosi
dobbiamo vedere
mi sono punta o no c'è qualcosa ma
guarda tu sei un pozzo
era un po
effettivamente ci sono dei disegni la
soglia che cosa c'è disegnato lì sopra
non c'è è un certo tipo ho un angelo in
tedesco e molto misterioso questo pozzo
perché è stato nascosto qua guardiamo
meglio cosa c'e raffigurato
guarda
riesce a vedere
sono due leoni per questo che è un
bottone gigante e di vallo nascosto di
un invaso futuro
pensa che stia semplicemente un fatto da
fiori non un bottone
un altro essere umano trasformato in
pietra guarda
ok abbiamo esplorato quasi tutti i
giardini del castello che hanno varie
statue
ma gli strani ora cerchiamo la feritoia
che nella nostra stanza dove il
passaggio così scopriamo il re da dove
ho messo una lettera ai
soci sono
quattro feritoie è una di queste
secondo me la feritoia giusta
questa qui
come fai sapere che quella è perché è
l'unica che sta all'altezza della nostra
stanza mi ha fatto il real salirà con la
sola guarda tra l'altro la sopra c'è la
statua di pietra di un falco
diamo faccia qualche pasta gioco metri
d'acqua è impossibile arrampicarti
arrivare la zona di deve avere
utilizzato qualche passaggio segreto
c'è una finestra con delle sbarre
forse sono le segrete del castello
meglio conta marsi
[Musica]
comunque a me non sembra un posto
stregato o malefico anzi mi sembra un
posto fiabesco per rivivere quarta
aspetta un attimo che cosa c'è lì
ho visto qualcosa su quel giappone dove
ad essere li ricorda
non vedo niente che cosa hai visto lo so
ho visto un'ombra sembrava come se ci
fosse una specie di fantasma affacciato
lì al balcone ma che dici fantasmi non
esistono
e poi perché dovrebbe affacciarsi al
balcone forse per spiare ci va bene
eppure digiuno che ho visto qualcosa là
sopra sembrava proprio un fantasma si
sta anche alzando il vento quindi io
come il presentimento che noi non siamo
ben graditi qua forse è meglio scappare
secondo me ti sta venendo un po di paura
ora beh torniamo in camera così ti passa
la paura non c'è nessun fantasma ma qua
sono solo leggende quelle dei fantasmi
nei cartelli dai andiamo pure fi conto
di una cosa molto importante
[Musica]
mentre io stavo parlando non è però
scontato ciò che lo dirò e allora perché
ai miei dato solo la buccia è perché la
confezione di tutto ci vuole dire il
resto non omaggiato dai subito in
prigione dai rivoluzione era così buono
guidare in prigione ci siamo dimenticati
di una cosa importantissima giornata
abbiamo già avanzato siamo dimenticati
una cosa importante vi ricordate la
scorsa lettera che abbiamo ricevuto dal
re nella lettera diceva vediamo se
trovate il cavaliere
cavaliere lo avete visto l'episodio
precedente andate a vederlo ora è meglio
che iniziamo a cercare subito il
cavaliere altrimenti non so cosa
potrebbe succedere ma non ci è arrivata
nessuna altra lettera ho quindi
sicuramente dobbiamo trovare il
cavaliere nello scorso episodio abbiamo
esplorato tutto il castello dallo sterno
ma non abbiamo esplorato tutto l'interno
del castello dobbiamo cercare il
cavaliere e video se riusciamo a trovare
siamo dentro al campo 6
[Musica]
[Applauso]
abbiamo trovato
trovato il cavaliere dobbiamo fare
silenzio per non disturbare
altri abitanti del castello
enorme
speriamo che non prenda vista ma
aspetta dice qualcosa qui
d'onore qui un po paura a prenderla però
guarda che cos'è
un'altra lettera del re questa la prima
o dopo
ora continuiamo ad esplorare il cartello
ma fate silenzio
guardate che è vista
visto
io comunque ancora un po paura di quel
tavoliere non volendo non controllare
che volere punti si è spostato per amica
non mi lasciare solo con questo
ma
ci sono tantissimi libri antichi
forse nascosta dentro a questi libri c'è
qualche segreto che dovremo scoprire
sono in tantissimi infatti si puà
facciamo leggerli tutti sembra
bellissima vista anche d'acqua
e voi vivreste qui o vi farebbe paura
che ci vivrei qui ma solo tu la
condizione se ci fossero tantissime cose
da mangiare io fossi seduto sul tavolo
potessi mangiare tutto quello che voglio
e mi dispiace informarti che non sei tu
il re anzi dobbiamo ancora conoscere
conoscerlo
effetti che questi amarezza si sento
delle voci
e qualcuno che ridà
forse questi sono gli abitanti del
castello di cui parlava di accusa coeli
ok non c'è niente qua
perché se sembra che si sia spostato era
sempre lì
ma non fatti adesso nessuno spazio si è
fatto più avanti non so perché ma un
brutto presentimento su questo cavaliere
voi forse si sta un momento
[Musica]
uscita e non lo so
stavo per cadere
siamo riusciti a scappare dal castello
sfortunata anche perché c'era qualcosa
di il cavaliere ha perso ma si parla di
strane ora dobbiamo solo aprire questa
lettera
forse meglio spostarsi la quale non
nemici dalle carte che mi sembra
un'ottima idea parla
[Musica]
stiamo uscendo dal cartello andiamo nei
giardini del castello così forza non
vorremmo a disturbarci ottime ne andiamo
devo dire che a quest'ora il castello è
bellissimo guarda
proprio faccio in questa panchina antica
forse non ci disturberà nessuno perché
stiamo bene così sì prima idea apriamo
una listino
cosa ci sarà questa volta
complimenti siete sopravvissuti
finora ma non è finita qui
anzi abbiamo appena cominciato
provate a nascondervi tra le mura del
mio castello ma attenti a non perdere di
o peggio attenti a non essere catturati
e chiusi nelle segrete per sempre le
segrete chi vincerà questa challenger
riceverà in dono un vestito nobile degno
del castello buona fortuna
il re come verrà chiuso nelle segrete
per sempre no perché cosa mangiano le
segrete stai sempre a pensar da mangiare
figlio che mi danno pane duro e acqua
come falso non hai più paura invece di
essere rinchiuso per sempre nella
prigione del castello si è rinchiuso
perfetto perché ero così non posso più
mangiare quello che voglio vabbè
comunque che cosa dobbiamo fare
esattamente dice provate a nascondervi
tra le mure del mio cartello attenti a
non perderli quindi dobbiamo
semplicemente giocare a nascondino e chi
vince vincerà un vestito nobile del mio
del castello io lo vorrei si cela una
conversione investito un obbligo del
tempo lo vorrei proprio vuole io non mi
fiderei tanto potrebbe essere maledetto
anche il vestito magari a qualche
talismano qualche bottone io sto in ogni
caso dobbiamo iniziare subito alla
challenge
altrimenti si arrabbierà e potrebbe
chiudersi entrambi nelle segrete voi
lasciate un mi piace per portarci
fortuna chi si nasconde per primo
nasconditi tu per prima così io magari
posso andare alla ricerca di cibo così
la verità è che magari se ci prendono
possiamo avere del cibo nelle segrete
entrare in anticipo questo noi
nasconditi così almeno so che non sarei
andato a cercare cibo forte ne vai
inizia nasconderti fino a quanto dovrò
contare conto fino a 30
no 2 chi ebbe
ibba mi stavo dimenticando che devo
cercare vitale ok iniziamo a cercarlo
perdevo di riuscire a trovarlo presto e
di non dover girare il castello da sola
inquietante girare questo castello da
sola forse era questo il piano del re
fin dall'inizio separarci e farci stare
da soli vediamo se è qua sopra
dove si era nascosta qui non c'è nessuno
la giuso il castello
cose che
ti troverò
vediamo
dove si sentito
è una statua non è vitale o no non
riesco a trovarlo se fosse stato preso
da qualcuno devo pensare vitale dove si
nasconderebbe pitali si nasconderebbe
dove c'è il cibo quindi forse è
rientrato da solo dentro al castello
fisso qualcosa ha nessun valore là sopra
vediamo senza rompere qua anche se avevo
già controllato
ma
c'è qualcosa là dietro
oggi credo
vitale
chi ha trovato
o con il bravissimo
benissimo
il rapporto devo buttare
1234567 dove stai andando 8
udc uno dei tre dei feriti sensi tetti
che ravetti che trovi 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 13
tardiamo cercare di un so dove sia
nascosta sicuramente è andata nel roseto
perché anita allora le rose quindi
andiamo a vedere per prima cosa nel
roseto e questo e clicchiamo inferiore
del giardino qui mi sembra di vedere nel
montali poi fatemi sapere che se lo
vedete sono quasi sicuro che le sta
nascosta
allora
queste roseto
però non l'avevo qui
queste saranno oltre altra parte
ma
ho visto qualcosa muoversi dietro quale
l'albero
sì sì c'è proprio qualcosa che si muove
di avere quell albero
andiamo andiamo a controllare più da
vicino ma che è proprio dietro quell
albero
adesso la spaventiamo
perché sono bravissimo nascondigli di
stare ferma quando giochi a nascondino
rumori
non vi ho fatto vedere il mio ospiti di
oggi oggi ho una magliettina celeste con
i cuori mary è una gonnellina
nera b piazze
quest'estate sono inquietanti sembra che
mi osservino realmente comunque devo
puntare
22 30 andiamo alla ricerca di vitale
secondo medita ne esce
del castello
di un giardino così ma
ma quello
ma è vitale ma pensa davvero che sia
nascosto di doppione meno nascosto si
vede benissimo soprattutto con quella
maglietta gialla che è andato lì vabbè
andiamo a prenderlo come se io non lo
vedessi
tanto
che ho già preso
evitare sta scappando ma io l'ho già
visto quindi ha già perso non c'entra
che lui scappi stesse confuse sul gioco
a cui stiamo giocando vitale male che ti
ho già visto
[Musica]
e mezzi di essere invisibili
[Risate]
non ti stessi nemmeno nascosta really
rannicchiato perché mi sei mezzo lino
pensavo che funzionasse la magia
dell'invisibilità no in realtà mi sono
messo lì perché c'è la porta della
cucina e prospettando che uscisse un
co.co.co si potesse fare non ci credo ti
sei messo lì solo perché c'è la cucina
in effetti non è questo il momento di
mangimi prodotti nella challenge
altrimenti dovrei si arrabbierà tocca a
me nascondermi si sente
nel frattempo che cerco il mio
nascondiglio stava un po guardando gli
alberi perché io adoro gli alberi sono
bellissimi hanno tutto questo libro è un
po strano guardate
posto dentro
dopo ho mai visto un albero così magari
contiene qualche segreto dentro qualche
abitante per i un albero magico
anche questo ramo è molto particolare da
solo bello questo albero ad ora gli
altri che arrivò un posto a lei pensa ad
altro di tanto del castello con un modo
semi terra
guarda
[Musica]
ti ricordi di quel terrazzo dove avevi
visto qualcosa di strano mia vendetta
certo con lo ricordo fa pure paura
vabbè meglio che ci sbrighiamo perché
sta facendo buio è meglio non giocare a
nascondino al buio ok ragazzi per
nascondermi penso che l'ultimo turno ho
deciso di farlo un po difficile corazza
nessuno queste sono le mura del castello
guardate
tipo corridoio fatto di piante
bellissimo andiamo qui vediamo cosa c'è
speriamo di non perderci
[Musica]
quasi una torre del castello
questa famiglia del castello
di cappello
[Musica]
guardate ho trovato il nascondiglio
perfetto
un biglietto
trovato il nascondiglio perfetto questo
corridoio del castello guardate la
dietro se il castello secondo me
l'italia non mi troverò mai vinsero la
challenge e secondo voi chi vincerà
e ora aspettiamo e speriamo che scada il
tempo cambiamo aria del castello adesso
vediamo serenità sia nascosta qui da
qualche parte
qui in effetti ci sono degli ottimi
nascondigli e sono sicuro che anita si
sia nascosta proprio qui magari acqua
dietro
ma che è proprio nascosta questa torre
tono della vedetta no sembra proprio che
non sia qui continuiamo a cercarla
vita dove sei si sia nascosta proprio
dietro la grande muraglia del castello
andiamo a controllare quest'altro torre
magari è proprio qui che si nasconde
e no non si nasconde neanche qui adesso
sta pure diventando buio
devo sprecare
è troppo distratto pensare al cibo si è
accorto che sono in questo corridoio
niente mi sa che il tempo è scaduto
quindi posso uscire dal mio la famiglia
e dirgli che aperto
spaventiamo
dove
talete di nascondersi
non dico bravo mi dà la vita vinto
[Musica]
c'è qualcosa quella finestra del
castello ma che cos'è secondo me si sta
osservando
huertas ovvero nascosta
è un gradino della torre tu sei passato
con i sottotitoli
questo significa solo una cosa o pinto
le sale di ora dovrei avere un vestito
reale investito reale nel senso che non
è virtuale al reale non in quel senso
una forza minuto torniamo perché si sta
facendo bene ci sono varie cose alle
finestre del castello e vero facciamo la
strada del ritorno assieme se c'è
qualcosa di strano lo vedrete in più voi
[Musica]
lei
bellissimo gente non ti sporgere troppo
cosa mercati in qualche buco ma smentito
ecco il terrazzino da cui vitale aveva
visto qualcosa ok queste sono le nostra
scarichiamo
[Musica]
non si apre
cioè non è chiusa fuori
la carta
guarda
io se questo
guarda c'è il simbolo del lupo o meglio
del re però non era argentato il tour ha
fatto
forse il premio per aver vinto la
challenge silvia volumi che si fabbrica
è un vestito reale come diceva nella
lettera sembra bellissimo
vediamo
[Musica]
perché
bellissimo
cosa c'è di che cos'è e le maniche una
manica cena
mi sento un ordinata ma del castello era
una battuta ha fatto già pezzi il
vestito non è che vorrà fare a pezzi a
chiedere smettila
se
questa tanto paglietta no no no
ma bellissimo
a voi piace questo vestito
secondo voi dovrei provare lo lasciò di
un mi piace se volete che mi provi il
mio nuovo investitore ale tri andar in
giro per il castello con questo vestito
da darmi gennari e solo pò geloso però
che il red abbia fatto questo regalo
non devi essere geloso in bellissimo
vestito sei geloso perché se il mio
fidanzato ma no sono geloso perché il
renon ha regalato anche a me ha un bel
vestito magari una bella armatura da
cavaliere
patteggiano solo per quello
mi hai detto nemmeno bene ti piace
questo vestito e se vi sarebbe bene si è
molto bello questo vestito però
ricordati che questo vestito lontana
regalato il re è praticamente tu hai
detto questo vestito perché io non ti ho
trovato è quindi se io non ti ho trovato
da chi ovviamente questo vestito come se
lo avesse regalato io eh vabbè poi
lasciato mi piace se volete che mi provo
pesto belli in un sentito e nel prossimo
episodio lo proverò a destra la prossima
challenge del resto
non c'è nessuna lettera qua e la
prossima lettera sicuramente dovremo
trovarla ma dove
cerchi siamo al buio
siamo nel castello siamo ancora qui all
buglio abbiamo deciso di fare una
challenge e cioè
esplorare il castello al nuovo
se vi state chiedendo che i capelli
strani che hai anita perché non li ho
piastrati questo in realtà sono i miei
capelli e naturale gol bellissimi
ondulati mulas traboccato per piastra
rica non abbiamo un cuore trovato
un'altra lettera quindi non abbiamo
nessuna nuova lettera del re meglio che
cerchiamo in giro e magari riusciremo a
trovarla poi lasciato un mi piace per
portarci fortuna e dovremo parlare a
voce bassa perche notte anche voi se
volete immergervi asti ma noi nella
challenge
vedete se notate qualcosa di strano e
ora pronti cucina è così siamo qua fuori
questo è il nostro balconcino il
problema è che anche sei tardissimo non
è ancora buio completamente sta facendo
buio sempre più tardi noi inizieremo a
fare un giro comunque assieme a voi e
aspetteremo che arrivi la notte
il lato via la
mattina
ultimo il cappello questo tramonto
quella stupendo
senti tutti questi rumori sono le cicale
là sopra sull'albero
e si stanno cantando
così spiegato le città regalando
la loro canzone
si sveglia nella scala e cliccati lo so
che cantone chissà se le scale cosa ma
questo è il mio albero preferito anche
se io amo tutti gli aspetti
bellissimo sai come si chiama
quest'albero come si chiama io un letto
e non è un abitante di lecce
è davvero magico quest'ora il castello
dovrebbe essere per usa se non sbaglio
loro per uso scendiamo giù nel giardino
del castello e se troviamo qualcosa
questo è il tunnel di piante del
castello il tunnel camp ital
guardate che bella questa pianta tipo
rosta e stupenda
bellissimo il colore vabbè per tutto il
video anita vitale che parlano e si
innamorano delle piante degli alberi ep
per non parlare dei cipressi quanto sono
ben guardate sono quelli sono quegli
alberi lunghi lunghi ea punta non sono
quelli sono altissimi
ora siamo nel roseto le rose sono uno
dei miei fiori preferiti gli altri miei
fiori preferiti sono le begonie più
belle sono bianche bianchissime e hanno
messo tutta qua dentro con i bianchi
gianni pastorino delle proteasi ritmica
poi ci sono delle rose rosa qualche
grande
a voi piacciono le piante i fiori gli
alberi scrivetecelo nei commenti quali
sono i vostri fiori preferiti abbiamo
sopra
ok devo smetterla di fissarmi con i
fiori e gli alberi andiamo di qua
cerchiamo dell'indigenza è quasi buio
vedi nonno anche acceso le luci al
cappello queste teste sono più
inquietanti adesso
cambiato espressione sia vogliate
è illuminato invece sta guardando la
sotto se ci saranno scorto qualcosa da
sotto
non c'è niente ora vi di trovare cibo
concreti come così
sei riuscita a vederci ci siamo seduti
qua in questa panchina nel parco del
castello e stiamo aspettando di sentire
o vedere qualcosa magari arriverà
proprio il re di persona sì siamo qui
nel giardino insieme alle sue statue
magari verrà proprio qui ad incontrarci
non me lo sapremo cosa dobbiamo fare se
possiamo tornare a casa sentiamo liberi
insomma che cosa dovremmo fare
che cos'era
hai visto dove siamo dove siamo guardate
la sopra c'è il terrà spedì magari ci
vuole dire qualcosa
vai tu a parlarci io non ci vado io mi
allontano proprietà no non mi lasciare
tutto l'aspettavi sorpa urali questa
sveglia si è visto la runa la
la luna è quasi piena loaf and death e
abbiamo pochissimo tempo per risolvere
questo mistero questo enigma questa
maledizione vi spieghiamo 5 magari
andiamo dirà
ok ma non avviciniamoci al terrazzo ok
[Musica]
queste forse sono le sette reti ci sono
le spadare
ho sempre tuo favore ma su
si andiamo a controllare
entrato io non c'entro ok aiuto
ma non si vede vieni per cento la luce
qui non c'è nessuno
aspetta
manuale non c'è nessuno sento che hai
detto che è sentito un rumore qua
servizio suo pro
o poi avete sentito qualcosa
cup in corso
[Musica]
non vogliamo forti verbale che che cosa
sei mi ha chiesto se vuoi fare del male
il nonno vai pure via da questa stanza
seguì poi esplorare le altre stanze del
castello quando sarà anche il giardino
con le rose pro basta che vai via
grazie c'ero
andato via davvero scomparso questo che
sia la dietro il trono a roma la di non
penso che sia andato via non controllare
la
mia bastata questa come esperienza e fa
bene vado io controllare se ci vai tu
questa volta io c'ho troppo paura che
toccano la vostra cosa succede qualcosa
che mi subito controllare che io sto qui
s'è andati in bagno poi prendere un
cuscino modelli di modelli verranno
cucinate in testa meglio non faccia
arrabbiare lui effettivamente regione
anita stai attenta accendi la luce
vendita
che successo
insomma gli scherzi mai pago c'è nessuno
aveva una vita
anita perché non ti sento più
non mi stai facendo un altro scherzo
vero
dai non mi pare un altro scherzo però
anita
la vita è successo guarda
[Musica]
a vista possiamo degli abitanti di cui
ci ha parlato il re entrato lì
ma ci sia qualcosa guarda
abbassato la prossima lettera o non ho
capito una cosa ma qua dietro c'è per
caso una volta una porta che è sparita
per questo che c'è questo simbolo qua
strano porta segreta dobbiamo trovare il
mattone giusto vabbè ci pensiamo dopo
ora leggiamo la lettera si sente ma che
cosa c'è scritto nella lettera sia
proprio una lettera ufficiale del re al
suo stand max perché l'ha lasciata il
fantasma forse non suo messaggero
apriamo la
cosa dice questa vita complimenti siete
ancora vive
però non mi abbia toccato nessuno
abitante del castello altrimenti avrete
una maledizione che vi terrà
intrappolati qui per sempre
per fortuna siamo stati a distanza
altrimenti saremmo rimasti prigionieri
qui nel male sono rimasto all'ingresso
non mi sono avvicinato troppo la
prossima lettera si trova nel punto più
alto del castello buona fortuna e
attenti a non cadere in rete inter non
cadere allora deve essere proprio in
alto la prossima lettera forse intende
sul tetto dobbiamo salire sul tetto
protetto dal castello sembra troppo
ovvio che sia quello il punto più alto
del castello secondo me è più difficile
secondo voi a torre del castello che non
ci resta che andare a salire sopra il
castello a cercare di andare il più in
alto possibile e provare a non cadere
sperando che non ci siano altri abitanti
presenze strane là sopra neanche
presenza ci potrebbero essere là sopra
arcieri
forse un drago
non penso non esistono i draghi di
sicuro non esistono non esistono neanche
i fantasmi eppure mi sembrava un
fantasma
magari è lui che ci vuole fare qualche
scherzo sto cercando di spaventarci non
dobbiamo farsi demoralizzare mai
lasciate un mi piace portarci fortuna ho
messo il vestito che mi è stato regalato
dal re mi piace come mi sta benissimo
e ora dovremo andare nella parte più
alta del castello e vedere se troviamo
qualcosa vi ricordate lo scorso video la
corsa challenge brighiamo sì perché
sembra che sia per piovere allora
secondo me per raggiungere la parte più
alta del castello dobbiamo salire sopra
le torri pero
le trophy mi sembrano alla parte alta o
forse quella porta quale sarà la torre è
giusta il problema è che si sta anno
volando dobbiamo sbrigarci prima che
arrivi il temporale
[Musica]
stiamo salendo sempre di più
vi ricordate questo passo nel castello o
avvicinato per mestre circa maria sì io
mi porto il club
ma se devo dire
questa è la libreria del castello per le
ricordate ma questo non è il punto più
alto del castello dobbiamo continuare a
salire vero troviamo nelle altre strade
magari ci portano ancora più su ci sono
delle scale direttore di the guarda
noi abbiamo ancora esplorate questa
aspetta però mi è venuto un dubbio
questa e la prossima lettera terreni
fosse nascosta nella libreria meglio
controllare no ci contiamo
dove potrebbe essere ci sono talmente
tanti libri i libri sono tantissimi e
sono anche in lingue strano e non riesco
a capirli
e impossibile cercare tutti questi libri
magari il mistero e il segreto è
racchiuso qua ci vorrebbero mesi per
controllarli tutti la città proviamo a
salire al piano di sopra
ok
siamo attenti a non svegliare il
cavaliere andiamo
a
dire
lascia la pace vogliamo disturbarlo
sarebbe giusto vedere se era sveglio
come stesso cavaliere risveglio
vedi st addormento
storia possiamo farci un self insieme
forse si entra viola
forse siamo nel punto più alto del
castello
ci sono delle ragazze qua
vediamo
siamo sul tetto del castello
[Musica]
tra loro appelli
ora dobbiamo solo cercare la prossima
lettera quale sarà la parte più alta
esploriamo tutto assieme e voi lasciate
un mi piace per portarci fortuna finite
guardate qua c'è il chiostro dove
eravamo primi guardando
siamo proprio in alto sarà il punto più
alto del castello forse questa torre qui
ma forse questa donna
ne facciamo ieri è stato un attimo c'è
anche una torre ancora più alta bimbo
possiamo provare a salire con delle funi
no è troppo pericoloso e poi guardate
che nuvole sta per arrivare un temporale
dobbiamo sprecarsi c'è anche tanto vento
lo vendiamo continuiamo ad esplorare il
terrazzo partner fortuna non c'è nessuna
creatura strana finora
di buchi magari mi possa arrampicare da
qui da fermo fermo è troppo pericoloso
non puoi arrampicarsi salgo quassù non
arrampicarti troppo pericoloso ok
guardarci un altro passaggio può passati
questa attenta a
questa parte interna del castello non
l'avevo ancora vista sono un sacco di
parti del castello che non abbiamo
ancora esplorato in su che bel panorama
né potrebbe essere nascosta
su queste cose
scusa
controlliamo in ogni feritoia del
castello ok non servivano questo
territorio
ma che bel paesaggio da
fare sono troppo basse arrivo
dove dovremmo andare adesso
ma per sony tutti c'è qualche altro
passaggio ma vieni qua
questo è quanto
[Musica]
e bellissimo vedere il roseto e il parco
del giardino dall'alto dove siamo stati
gli altri giorni vi ricordate guardate
forse c'è qualcosa qua sotto
[Musica]
ero dimenticata che ho paura delle
altezze
che sono simbolo che questo che cosa
vorrà dire
pietra sono caduta guarda la lettera o
pacco rollando il muro allora
penso che s'era sulla moto villa con il
sito ho paura che ho paura proprio che
succeda quello che provo a sfilarla
piano stai attenta vedo dire a quella
pietra si muova devono sempre
esattamente dove altrimenti scatterà una
trappola
ok non lasciatevi dovere di una lettera
per reja perché al sigillo con il lupo
non apriamo la quante anche opere già
pericoloso potrebbe crollare in
qualunque momento dormivamo il piano di
sotto e leggiamo la geniale
cavalli
sì siamo super fatto
la scheda
mi sono dovuta vedere il quale un
momento per riposarmi perché queste
scarpe fanno male
il problema è che stiamo n'era tanta e
qui c'è il cavaliere mi fate per il
cavaliere facciamo una sfida chi riesce
a toccare il cavaliere a scappare cioè
paura iniziato beh effettivamente tu con
quelle scarpe però se un po in
svantaggio perché io posso correre
meglio per vincere
questa cordata tra la sua maschera
hai visto non è successo niente
per fortuna e grossisti
piani ma che non siamo ancora in quanto
mancano ancora un paio di piani ma per
fortuna la lettera qui con me
ragazze abbiamo scoperto una stanza
segreta bellissima sembra la sala comune
di corvonero ora di di bella
[Musica]
e io invece sono riuscito a riparare la
lettera che vuol leggere la lettera nel
parco del castello così forse non
verremo disturbati da nessuno
siamo seduti al parco del castello
ormai lo conoscerete bene e apriamo la
nostra prossima lettera dal re vediamo
cosa si scritto
vi state divertendo il mio castello
maledetto
la vostra nuova prova da superare sarà
trovare tutti i mostri di pietra ma
attenti a non farli arrabbiare o peggio
attenti a non farli tornare in vita
seguito la mappa e buona fortuna
il re seguite la mappa quindi dobbiamo
spostarci da questo castello dobbiamo
andare da un'altra parte è meglio che
controlliamo la mappa e vediamo dove
dobbiamo andare sì andiamo a prenderla
se dobbiamo andar via da qua mi
dispiacerà un sacco perché anche se un
po inquietante mi ero affezionato a
questo castello dei ragazzi e così qua
in camera questa è la mappa vediamo
subito la nostra prossima tappa si noi
siamo qua al castello
dobbiamo andare dai mostri di pietra
seguendo questo percorso
dobbiamo arrivare qua quindi questi sono
i mostri di pietra credo dice che
dobbiamo trovarli tutti siete pronti a
finire con la prossima tappa lasciato
uni piace qui sotto per vedere il
continuo
oggi stiamo andando via dal castello
purtroppo è stato bellissimo stare in
questo castello anche se a volte c'era
qualcosa di strano ma è stato
prontamente se non avete visto gli altri
episodi andate poi a vederlo ora stiamo
in direzione parco dei mostri
non vediamo l'ora di vedere tutti molto
in questa è la nostra challenge di oggi
pronti più alta pranzo salutare e
pregano che l'aiuta la zona
ciao ragazzi siamo al sacro bosco il
parco dei mostri questa è la nostra
mamma ora ve la facciamo vedere che
abbiamo trovato il primo mostro
eccolo qua
vediamo tutti i mostri che dovremo
trovare guardate allora noi siamo qua
questo è il primo mostro che si chiama
proprio
l'auto e ora andiamo a vedere tutti gli
altri mostri la fine del pd scriveteci
qual è quello che vi è piaciuto di più
per questi mostri anche noi viviamo il
nostro preferito è bellissimo qua il
sacro bosco
[Musica]
champions
siamo vicini alla tartaruga guarda
ancora c'è una tartaruga gigante
[Musica]
20 mag
[Applauso]
[Musica]
guardate questa cosa o così sembra che
stia per crollare
proviamo ad entrare dentro evitiamo con
me
[Musica]
rinchiusi
che stranissimo sembra di essere pizzi
per sorpasso
ho
sentito questo rumore è un canto
tra il canto dei mostri o delle sirene
poi ho sentite
andiamo verso il suono del tanto vediamo
che harmos ritroviamo sì
[Musica]
questo è l'orco
[Applauso]
[Musica]
e anita
forse è meglio sistemi un po attenta ma
sta entrando nella bocca dell'orco
sì
fa un po impressione
permesso
tempo di euro
ma
principato data d'uscita onorevole
[Applauso]
[Musica]
per la mamma
ed è stato questo elefante del grande e
più bello
marcate
questo invece è entrato guardate che per
l'euro
l'accusa
[Musica]
è
dove il cane riuscite a vederlo qua
[Musica]
se cerbero il cane a tre teste come in
harry potter puffi thing urtati
[Musica]
portate questa sembra l'apertura della
camera dei segreti
[Applauso]
[Musica]
chissà se a un'apertura segreta che
portano qualche parte anche come tante
che dall'altra parte c'è da scoprire
e così qua ci siamo seduti qua nella
panchina del sacro bosco è bellissimo ma
dimmi un po qual era il tuo mostro
scultura preferito miei mostri preferiti
erano l'orco bellissimo davvero e poi la
donna dormiente anche se non era un vero
e proprio mostro però la scultura era
bellissima che c'era il cane c'era il
cagnolino al fianco sia le mie preferite
erano un orco notes bellissimo poi il
drago nero e
santena sirena mi è piaciuto
e le vostre preferite qual'erano
scrivetelo nei commenti
e ora continuiamo il nostro viaggio
stanotte arriveremo in un altro posto in
cui dormire vi faremo vedere la prossima
tappa quindi pronti
dal parco dei mostri siamo scesi ancora
funzioni in macchina ora siamo in
abruzzo
qua c'è vitale e nuova vita
questa è l'entrata
è grandissima
letto tv e anche di fare lo ammetto
quasi del cibo che bisogna raccontare
abitare le cose che la fa sparire niente
che so se c'è dell'altro cibo così anna
c'è proprio niente ti preoccupare perché
ero più tardi
abbastanza e che ce l'ha vista sul mare
su un bellissimo terrazzo
c'è anche il tramonto
che relazzo
ora torniamo ad esplorare dentro cosa
stai facendo
che cosa ai trenta ho trovato
sono bio adesso che le cose nei frega
degli hotel portano tantissimo e quindi
lasciano un
giusto però insistono a mangiare quasi
un'altra fine tranquillo abbiamo visto
il bagno
ma quale sarà la nostra prossima tappa
la nostra prossima challenge non c'è
nessuna lettera abbiamo seguito la mappa
siamo arrivati qua ma dobbiamo aspettare
la prossima lettera per capire qual è la
prossima alle porte qua
è stato tale da rete abbattuta ritrovo
non abbiamo ancora trovato la nuova
lettera quindi non possiamo continuare
la challenge
[Musica]
ieri non ho controllato qua ci sono le
valigie anche
meno abbiamo guardato qua però
cosa è quello ve lo ricordate che si è
uno dei mostri del parco dei mostri
giusti era l'orco del parco dei mostri
guarda la lettera era tutto il tempo
presto leggiamo la vediamo cos'altro si
aspetta questo che cosa vorrà dire però
che non sia un talismano che ci porta
sfortuna
secondo poi dovremo tenerlo o dovrei
lasciarlo qui da qualche parte scrivete
nei commenti vediamo qual è la nostra
prossima challenge
c'è scritto benvenuti siete quasi giunti
alla fine del viaggio una delle vostre
ultime prove fra di vedere dei lupi veri
attenti a non farli arrabbiare sono
affamati firmato il re ho capito perché
nella mappa ci sono dei simboli dei lupi
dobbiamo andare a vedere i lupi veri ma
o sono emozionatissimo perché ho sempre
voluto vedere dei lupi veri però dice
che sono affamati cerchiamo di stare
attenti ok e questo caso lo lascio qua
non si sa mai che mi porti sfortuna
andiamo subito a vedere i lupi veri e
voi verrete con noi ma lasciate un mi
piace qua sotto mi raccomando pronti
eccoci qua ci troviamo nell'area
faunistica del lupo a pretoro dove viene
appunto salvaguardata la specie noi ci
siamo emozionati
tantissimo nel vedere dei veri lupi dal
vivo ovviamente dovevamo fare il
silenzio per non disturbarli ed eravamo
in una struttura lontana i punto da non
spaventarli come potete vedere sono
bellissimi appunto noi ci siamo
emozionati
tantissimo nel branco c'è sempre il capo
branco che il maschio alfa che poi
seguito dalla sua compagna con la
compagna formano una coppia monogama
quindi stanno insieme per tutta la vita
[Musica]
non possiamo tornati a casa anche se io
sto riguardando il vestito da
principessa e sognando ancora di essere
al castello ma purtroppo siamo qui a
torino
grazie
berlino mida sembri tanti baci
c'è un problema però anche se abbiamo
fatto col ghiaccio siamo stati nel
castello siamo stati al parco dei mostri
abbiamo visto i lupi abbiamo superato
pari al challenge ma non abbiamo ancora
vinto la sfida finale si ricordi nella
prima lettera diceva che dovevo vincere
la sfida finale il problema è che sta
per tornare la luna piena guarda al
tramonto vero si sta avvicinando la
notte come faremo adesso beh forse
facciamo in tempo a trovare una
soluzione prima che arrivi la re una pmi
ritrasformi di nuovo vi ricordate
l'ultima volta capitolo trasformata che
cosa è successo rischierei di mangiare
vitali e rossi io me lo ricordo bene
però io non voglio essere mangiato io
voglio voglio mangiare invece è insomma
ti sembra il momento di pensare a
mangiare adesso potremmo trasformarmi un
lupo mannaro completo e tu potresti
essere frenato dobbiamo trovare una
soluzione subito seri il re ha lasciato
qualche lettera o forse voleva e ieri
trasformarsi per completare la sfida
finale non lo so lo dobbiamo sbrigarci
chiediamo come sempre a berlino che lui
sta tutto sei merlino e il merlino vi
servite sei aiutato in tutte le nostre
sale
potresti dirci
come devo fare quando vorrei
trasformarmi il lupo guardare
grazie per i balzini ma che cosa vorrà
dire aspettà aspetto aspettati voluto
libera magari visto che sta diventando
buio adesso ti trasformi se ti porto
qualcosa da mangiare così mangi domus e
ti trasformi non mangerei me non so se
si è capito però ti do da mangiare prima
così non mangimi e dopo
non credo che funzioni ma possiamo
provare lo stesso non abbiamo oltre
alternative che cosa prendere subito
ciao
ragazzi secondo voi vitale è andato in
cucina davvero a portarmi da mangiare
oppure era una scusa per andare lui a
mangiare
[Musica]
trasformazione già iniziata
enoch già
iniziate e nuvole vengono portate questo
per cercare di fermare la tua fame
la tua fa bene o casomai quei tu mi
mangi visto che spenderemo adesso
niente a me una coda che cosa perché i
portato le cose alla fine per me le stai
mangiando tu perché se si giocano sul
modo ormai no no no che siano già
trasformato sono solo spuntate le
orecchie mancano ancora i denti aguzzi
gli occhi gialli le zampe
la coda e poi che cosa l'altra sera non
meritano più quindi la trasformazione
completa in cui divento un lupo mannaro
zappino e vengo a cercarti sto mandando
tenere nervoso
ho capito devo 3 farlo solo
se sta succedendo
o no forse
il tutto il filo di pacchiano qua dentro
pato che magari posso prendere anche per
cibo sì sì mi sembra un'ottima idea ci
sono metodi perfetto ten devo dire mi
sembra un'ottima idea alla tua di uscire
fuori così io me lo posso stare un po di
tutto è
nato a berlino ma che strano pure mi
sento ancora me stesso segio con
l'istinto d'allungo vita le gioie come
farlo tornare
partita è
vivo
come la festa d'addio per la tua
incolumità ravallo a chiudere di buoni
giardino 2016 a chiave mi sembra mi
sembra la tv mi raccomando montenegro
doccia
ospiterà nato dalla trasformazione
sperando di non riuscire a entrare
dentro casa durante la notte con la luna
piena e arriva la mattina e tu sei
ancora vino per andato tutto bene
devo assolutamente pensare a qualcosa
cosa posso fare
un iter proprio là fuori
guardate vi faccio vedere
le cose non stanno andando per il verso
giusto non la vedo più andiamo lite con
me eccoci qua stiamo vicino alla porta
[Musica]
con sé gente comune dell'umanità come ti
senti
forse meglio se chiudo la porta
[Musica]
cerca di prendermi che cosa sta facendo
sta prendendo le mosche
no sto entrando dentro casa quindi se
esco fuori anita mi mangia se ne sto
dentro e aspetto è arriva la luna piena
e anita si trasforma del tutto c'è solo
una persona che può aiutarmi ad esso vi
ricordate chi è chiamo chiamarlo the
great e
facciamo lupo grazie di essere venuto ad
aiutarmi
ecco vedi
sta arrivando la luna piena e ha vinte
da fuori e si sta trasformando
tutto procede secondo i piani e se di
sicuro è unita ed iva che si sta
trasformando il lupo la luna piena sta
arrivando
ok mi fido di te era allora ma sei
sicuro che non ci sia un'altra soluzione
ne sei proprio sicuro
quindi questa è l'unica soluzione
vorrei trovare una soluzione un pochino
più indolore non posso fare
qualcos'altro magari possiamo fare
qualcos'altro insieme
bene allora fa in modo che sia rapido
e ora cosa devo fare io
io devo andare alla vita cioè dal lupo
mannaro e portarla qui è come faccio se
vado fuori mi strana
[Musica]
quindi devo trovare una soluzione per
attirare la vita dentro e io rimanere
fuori
chiedo può rimanere fuori dalla porta
penso di potercela fare
la tirerò alla porta mi faccio seguire
fino qui nel frattempo scatta glielo
diano qualche parte
ok allora facciamo così tu nasconditi no
non è bisogno giustamente non hai
bisogno se il lupo ti lascio qui è
arrivo cioè nel senso arriva a qualità
c'è un ragazzino ho avuto un'idea
geniale per prendere anita cioè il lupo
mannaro ho pensato di trarre stir mi di
cappuccetto rosso
o
meglio cosa per attirare un lupo se non
travestirsi da cappuccetto rosso ecco
guardate mi manca solo il cestino e
biscotti ma meglio così perché
altrimenti mi sarei maggiore di tutti
cerchiamo anita magari a cui da qualche
parte che si nasconde in mezzo agli
alberi e io nasconderci
[Musica]
io ho provato a controllare un po qui ma
non vedo proprio nulla quindi magari
adesso mi sposto
sento dei passi dietro di me c'è
qualcuno dietro di me
lo stesso andando nella direzione
sbagliata è meglio farla da un'altra
parte modo tappa così la po sopra le
doppiette così la posso tirare dentro
casa come ha detto il lupo
[Musica]
ok manita lupo mannaro è entrata in casa
adesso dovrebbe incontrare il lupo che
la aspetta tutto procede secondo i piani
che cos'è questo rumore
forse è meglio che vado a controllare
[Musica]
la porta è chiusa
lo so si stanno dicendo euro
peccato che non capisco il cagnesco e
cioè volevo dire il lupesco
no
sarei proprio curioso di sapere che cosa
si stanno dicendo
no
qui si mette male
sta succedendo qualcosa di sarah ma
sembra che stiamo litigando ma potrò
davvero fidarmi del lupo spero proprio
di sì
[Applauso]
qui si mette male
[Musica]
non so se devo intervenire forse è
meglio di no tra due lupi magari esco
fuori sbranato
[Musica]
sembra che abbiamo smesso di litigare
c'è molto silenzio
[Musica]
forse è meglio iniziare ad entrare il
piano piano
[Musica]
anita stai per il lupo è scomparso il
comico dopo che viveva al piano di sopra
che cosa è successo mercoledì il lupo si
è sacrificato per te per farti tornare
normale è uno l'edizione del lupo
mannaro
esatto era questo che volevo dire con
prova finale non ci abbiamo pensato un
po meno
se dovuto sacrificare per me che
mancherà tanto anche a me purtroppo era
l'unica soluzione
gli ho chiesto se c'erano delle altre
possibilità per salvarti mi ha detto di
no quando mi dispiace un sacco mini ora
non più giovani di silver lupo però non
mi terzo numero più lungo ma nardo la
luna piena no per fortuna più riusciti a
vincere la challenge si ma qualcosa mi
dice che non sia finita qui
guarda che cosa c'è qualcosa per terra
cos'è
un era
una mezza luna ha lasciato il lupo
quando è scomparso cosa vorrà dire che
forse
come un talismano che mi proteggerà
dalla maledizione del lupo mannaro
beh speriamo di sì allora bellissima
grazie lupo per esserti sacrificato per
me ora forse riusciremo a stare più
tranquilli speriamo ma qualcosa mi dice
che abbiamo vinto questa challenge ma
non la battaglia beh speriamo che ora si
lasceranno in pace
verrà più nessuno a disturbarci
forse
[Musica]